his super intelligence destined to be
our friend or foe one thing seems
certain the first computer that can
really outsmart us will have a
transformative effect on humankind the
development of full artificial
intelligence and super intelligence
would be one of the most important
things that has ever happened in human
history I mean arguably more important
than anything in human history and
perhaps comparable to the rise of Homo
sapiens in the first place Nick Bostrom
is a researcher at the University of
Oxford he's exploring the impact a super
intelligent machine could have on life
as we know it from an evolutionary
perspective intelligence is key it
helped humans to the top of the food
chain enabling them to build up powerful
civilizations what capabilities what a
super intelligent computer have after
all the edge humans had over other
species has enabled us to rule the world
now the fate of the gorillas depend a
lot more on what we humans do then on
what the gorillas do themselves so the
thought is that for basically the same
reasons if we one day create machines
that surpass human intelligence then
they might be in a very powerful
position to shape the future according
to their preferences and if that were to
pass it would then be of paramount
importance that the goals of these super
intelligences would be aligned with
human goals that they would be an
extension of the human will that they
would be fundamentally on our side
a super-intelligent computer would be
able to expand its own intelligence
enhancing its ability to analyze reason
develop and plan it could even outdo us
in terms of creativity because if you
think about it once you have machines
that can do everything that we can do
and can do it better and faster that's
really the last invention humans will
ever need to make because inventing is
itself one of these activities that then
will be done better by AI but a super
intelligence could develop and pursue
its own selfish goals that could lead to
a human style superiority complex
machines could treat us with the same
disregard we humans show a colony of
ants when we are say paving over a
parking lot similarly if you have a
super intelligent optimization process
that is optimum trying to optimize the
world for some objective that doesn't
include human values and the things we
care about then we might kind of be
analogously paved over or just destroyed
as a side effect and for instrumental
reasons rather than because of any
animosity so what can we do impose rules
on the machines such as do not harm any
human being it could easily see through
that
what about disabling it with a virus
chances are we wouldn't be smart enough
and pulling the plug doesn't seem to be
much of an option
either so you have a system that can
learn a system that is capable of
strategic thinking and planning that is
maybe able to anticipate your reactions
a system which for example if you
thought its goals would be better served
by not being switched off could plan
ahead and figure out a set of behavioral
outputs that would reduce the risk that
humans would choose to reach for the off
switch you have a system that
potentially is capable of deception like
humans even our and if you have a super
intelligent deceiver that presumably
could go much further
how could we stop a super-intelligent
computer from attacking the Internet
financial institutions the military
industry enslaving humankind and
generally wreaking havoc it seems that
the machine itself would have to come up
with the idea of goodwill towards humans
it looks like the most promising paths
involve leveraging the AIS own
intelligence its learning ability to do
some of this cognitive work for us maybe
you could have an AI that that learns
what it is that human values that looks
at human behavior
maybe asks us questions and then can
infer what our preferences are from God
programming a super intelligent computer
to live by basic human values sounds
pretty risky for Nick Bostrom though
it's a risk worth taking